c'est un triste record qui est tombée ce
dimanche 303 personnes sont décédées des
suites du coc vie 19 au portugal un
chiffre sans précédent pour le pays où
dix millions d'habitants
au coeur de la troisième vague pourtant
prudent depuis le début de la pandémie
mondiale le portugal assombri face aux
variants onglet du virus
les hôpitaux sont totalement saturés le
personnel médical a trop peu nombreux
face aux milliers de nouveaux cas chaque
jour face à cette crise sanitaire le
gouvernement portugais a dû se résoudre
à demander le soutien de l'union
européenne
un appel aussitôt entendue par plusieurs
pays
j'étais en contact avec le premier
ministre antonio costa en raison de la
situation sanitaire tendue au portugal
la pandémie de kovy 19 pose d'énormes
défis à tous les pays européens
il est impératif que la solidarité
européenne s'applique rapidement et sans
bureaucratie pour sauver des vies
humaines
l'autriche acceptera désormais des
patients en soins intensifs du portugal
autre initiative pour venir en aide au
portugal celle de l'allemagne ce
mercredi
huit médecins et du personnel soignant
qualifié ont été acheminés au portugal
avec 150 appareils de perfusion et 150
lits médicaux la pandémie qui sévit au
portugal depuis quelques semaines vous
le savez probablement tous est
clairement devenu problématique
la situation y est incomparablement plus
difficile qu'elle ne l'est ici chez nous
elle peut se développer à nouveau et
c'est pourquoi nous sommes nécessaires
là bas et nous ferons de notre mieux
des actes de solidarité à travers
l'europe auquel ne participe pas
directement la commission européenne
pour le moment mais pour lesquels elle
se dit prête à intervenir si nécessaire
notre sens de coordination des
interventions d'urgence suit de près la
situation critique liée à la pandémie de
kovy 19 au portugal et se tient prêt à
aider si le portugal demandent
l'assistance de l'union européenne
si la situation reste critique au
portugal des signes positifs semblent
apparaître plusieurs spécialistes jugent
que le pic de l'épidémie aurait été
atteint dans plusieurs régions du pays
le nombre de nouveaux cas quotidiens et
quant à lui au plus bas depuis le 5
janvier dernier alors que près de trois
cent quarante mille personnes
des vaccinés et des signes d'espoir pour
les portugais qui resteront confinées au
moins jusqu'au 14 février